la corte suprema británica no decidió
sobre si el gobierno maduro o el líder
de la oposición juan guaidó tiene poder
potestad sobre las 31 toneladas de oro
evaluadas en mil millones de dólares que
están en las bóvedas del banco de
inglaterra el tribunal superior remitió
este caso al tribunal comercial que debe
continuar con este proceso judicial que
inició en el 2018 cuando el gobierno de
maduro reclamó pidió al banco de
inglaterra la devolución de estas
reservas de oro lo que sí hizo la corte
suprema- hoy fue reconocer a juan guaidó
como presidente de venezuela tal y como
lo hizo desde 2019 el gobierno británico
el tribunal lamentó que este proceso se
haya complicado innecesariamente en los
tribunales británicos por la distinción
de quien es reconocido el presidente de
venezuela y concluyó esta mañana que lo
es juan guaidó tal y como ya lo ha hecho
el gobierno británico ahora el tribunal
comercial debe decidir si toma en cuenta
las decisiones judiciales de venezuela
sobre el control de este oro con este
fallo o juan guaidó avanza en con un
argumento bien importante para poder
reclamar las reservas de oro que están
en el banco de inglaterra en el futuro